good evening everyone this following
award has been called so many different
things over the years best engineering
effect special photographic effects
special visual effect computer-generated
effect or as I like to call it the we
don't need actors anymore we have
computers effects however we choose to
describe it this is the place where
cutting-edge filmmaking is happening
here are the nominees for achievement in
visual effects equal to horizon
Craig hammock Jason Snell Jason
Billington and Burt Dalton
dr. strange staff and Sarah T Richards
love Vincent forelli and Paul called the
jungle book Robert legato Adam Valdez
and who are Jones and Dan lemon
kubernetes Turing's Steve Emerson Oliver
Jones Brian McLean and Brad ship rogue
one a Star Wars story John no mo and Leo
how hickel's and Neil Corbeau and the
Oscar goes to the jungle book Robin the
guard saw Adam Valdez and who are John
diamond
this is the first Oscar win for
three-time nominee dan lemon first time
nominee Adam Valdez the third win for
four-time nominee Robert legato and
second win for three-time nominee Andrew
R Jones
[Music]
oh my god thank you this never gets old
by the way all great experiences start
at the very top and I have to say that's
alan horne who gave a fantastic job to
jon favreau a collaborative director
who's fantastic I literally
unprecedented support from all of the
Disney brass including Sean Bailey Dave
tartar Oh Sam
Dickerson Pete Toby and our producer
Brigham Taylor and then last but not
least these three gentlemen geniuses
behind me who commandeered a thousand
superb artists and contributed so
greatly and made so many winning
decisions that you know quite frankly
they actually got tired of winning like
that's a thing so I think I'm up I think
I'm done well thank you to all our
artists to the next round of applauses
for you you deserve it as much as we do
thank you so much